or satellite provider
indiana university bloomington professor
stephen andrews
teaches a class about conspiracy culture
in modern american society
he looks at the history of conspiracies
and why people believe for example the
earth is flat or the moon landing was
faked or that the 9 11 terrorist attack
was a government action
this 90-minute class is from american
history tv's lectures and history series
a weekly presentation on the weekends
all right so we uh
one of the things is we've got the
conspiracy believers we talked about the
what of conspiracies what did they
believe right
but now we also want to talk about the
why and how they believe how does this
conspiracy belief work in the ground who
are the people we're talking about what
do they look like what are the
communities like so we're going to talk
a little bit about that so
um
many if not all of our students are
going to come in with conspiracy beliefs
if you have had a conversation with any
of your students now
one of the things is that
people recognize that these beliefs
should not be spoken of quite often and
so you would give for example a lesson
on 9 11 in which you would have a class
of 30 students
perhaps go through a class go out and as
soon as they get out they're going to
turn to each other and go you know it
was an inside job
but not necessarily bringing up in class
depending on your class environment and
your class atmosphere i can tell you
that when i go and i sit down on a plane
and i tell somebody that i'm a historian
they tend to want to talk about the
civil war which i teach the civil war
that's great
if i tell them that i work on
conspiracies the floodgates are open to
an all kinds of
circus show that can come out right all
kinds of things from the very banal to
the highly and disturbingly specific
right so
it's important to think about how these
things work how these how widespread
they are where they are what causes
people to hold on to them because if we
see this only as part of
not us something we don't address
something we don't talk about then
it changes how we see these beliefs and
i also think
that
in a conversation in cliff who was here
said he had a conversation with high
school teenagers
and they these high school students
brought up conspiracy theories and he
had a really engaged conversation with
them that they really had
ideas about evidence and causality and
politics that he really he got to where
they actually are i know that in many of
the cases i teach a class called one
several classes that kind of touch on
this one called occult america and i can
tell you that in my class of h105 when i
talk about american history and i talk
about jackson's bank war my students
don't care
they'll learn it because i'm going to
ask them about it but emotionally the
thought of wildcat banking in kentucky
in the 1820s doesn't mean anything to
them bi-medalism
will we be crucified on a cross of gold
they're not really that concerned right
when we talk about these issues we get
underneath to what people actually
believe about how the world works and
it's hard and it's difficult and it can
be moving a lot of sideways directions
but to not do it i will try to make the
case
means that we're avoiding something that
they actually are engaged in a way they
actually think the world works right so
part of this michael shermer is a
well-known skeptic who is a debunker of
all kinds of different
you know idea fringe theories paranormal
stuff and he says we his goal is to
figure out why people believe weird
things it's a real problem with this
because we have to decide what are weird
things okay
um
when i say a conspiracy theorist who do
you imagine if you were an ad exec who
had to market to this demo
who is your demo you have some ideas so
we had talked a little bit so who is it
speak just from your heart your gut what
does a conspiracy theorist look like or
who are they give me some demo some
stuff demography
i really want you to
so but like the level of education
so
the more education one has but also like
the level like
one a group that's been targeted as like
one of the conspiracy yes so so and so
in other words you're
so you are far more nice and politically
kind and savvy than i want you so you
you would say lower education level
for educate for conspiracy this question
would be is the person
level but also if you're one of the
groups that's been targeted throughout
history as being one of the conspirators
so more likely to be able to likely to
believe that you're a conspiracy theory
because you're like well i'm not i'm not
like involved in the conspiracy like why
would that even be right okay all right
yeah so we gotta come
who feel wronged people who feel like
something
and have evidence right that they've
been
you know mistreated or
right or wronged in some way and that
goes so what does that person look like
well that's
when i could say when i go i ran into
this guy on a plane and he was a or or
and they were a conspiracy theorist
well that could be
poor
white maybe
people who see like people dying from
the opiate
epidemic people who don't have enough
money to poor white okay they're very
very very nice so i said she won't be
nice
white male cisgendered straight
um midwestern between the ages of
25 and 35
uh single where do they live what where
do they live
in a rural area in a rural area but
we're at where is their bed
their mom's basement right
like i have like i have to tell you what
look on behalf of every conspiracy
theorist that i have talked to
they are all very grateful that you are
very nice about the stereotype but we
know the stereotype right yeah go ahead
isn't that sort of thing after like
charlottesville and everyone came out
and they're like oh so many people said
this isn't who we were expecting to be
like fighting against
whatever like people were like shocked
at like the groups of people that were
emerging because it wasn't what they
expected because they were
khaki wearing white or white button-down
oxford wearing guys with short hair
like maybe this like image of what we
think the conspiracy theorist looks like
is not what they look like and you guys
are doing
my job i i appreciate and again she's
not a chill but she might as well be
which is exactly like when we talk about
conspiracy theories and you're right we
should open it up we should recognize
it's not everybody but there is
it's it's
it's this
right
right it's it's
it's
it's a per a male
possibly politically where do you think
they are
right so this this is the image a
right-wing male who's single without a
family lives in his parent that the real
stereotype lives in his parents basement
is on the internet right i mean like
donald trump said we don't know whether
it was russia or some 300 pound guy in
his basement right so this is he is
tapping into what is a cultural
stereotype of what a conspiracy theorist
looks like right we should think about
and you guys are already well down this
path of thinking this might be leading
us into some places we might not want to
go that because it may not be accurate
we need to think about it much more
right so
it's important to place any of the 911
truth or other words into a broader
system of beliefs about how the world
works right it is often misleading to
examine a single conspiracy separate
from a network of ideas so what do i
mean like i think if you say
there's bob he believes the moon landing
was a hoax and you want to argue with
bob about the moon landing it may be
that that's the only conspiracy theory
bob has
but my guess is if bob thinks that the
government has rigged a fake moon
landing he didn't think and then they
were done and let's go back to particip
participatory democracy right
like we've done our moon landing thing
now let's go back and be you know like
subject to the rule of the voters right
so these are networks of ideas right
they're part of a separate system of
american beliefs of what is possible in
and of itself what are the boundaries of
reality what are the boundaries of the
possible okay
so i mean in the sense you can say
depending on where you set those
boundaries you have a very different
idea of what is possible so i have given
you
and this is a real difficulty right we
don't know how to know what we all
believe
in a sense to the degree that we can
know what everyone else surrounds us
believe it's hard it's difficult so we
have questionnaires now these are
questionnaires that are not always
reliable but they should give us some
answer of what are the kinds of beliefs
that are out there in american society
first one i want to ask about a 2007 pew
poll of 35 000 people very well
respected in a major survey okay so this
was a big survey by pew there's another
one that's going to come out 35 000
people very good numbers nationwide
accounted for for race and ethnicity a
very good survey right so
what percentage of americans believe in
god or a universal spirit just just give
me a number 80 80.
75. well let's say let's 80-75
60 85 85
90. so we've gone to 60 to 90. most
people tend to be in the 70s
okay 70s
believe that god is a person with whom
you can have a relationship
so in other words what we're doing here
is moving away from those people who say
god is
in nature or gravity or some other force
to someone that i can pray to and have a
relationship with yeah
sixty
40
what else
80 okay so that number is lower than
your number of that believes in god or
universal spirit
yes
okay all right um believe in life after
death
80
80.
75.
how about believe in heaven
70
50. what 51
31
anyone at the anyone below 31
anyone above 80
but you have
90 how about believe in hell
is everyone's belief in hell below
belief in heaven
because we're all no you have it flipped
what is your what are your two numbers
50 60 okay
believe that scripture is the word of
god
40 60
50
okay
how about
believe that
miracles still occur today as in ancient
times which is both they occurred in
ancient times and they occur today right
so there's two parts what 20
40.
85 okay
what
75
75 80 so right how about believe that
angels and demons are active in the
world
all right
so
so here are some actual
numbers 92 of americans believe in god
or a universal spirit
even 21 of agnostics or atheists believe
60 believe that god is a person with
whom you can have a relationship 74
believe in life after death 74 believe
in heaven 59 believe in hell
and we are americans right so so i think
the americans tend to be more charitable
in the idea that they all want to go to
heaven and they're scared of hell they
were not raised in my church by the way
63 believe that scripture is the word of
god
is this more religious than
many of you imagined
yeah no i think they'll do it they did
it every 10 years so i don't think i
haven't seen the new numbers yet
a real trend you think in the united
states away from
yeah so the question is there's a real
difference between believing in religion
yes and attending church no no
yeah this is this is not certain
yeah no that's
there absolutely is a growth in the
unchurched right number of people who
that's right so but this is not about
church membership that's a whole
different set of numbers but yes but
there are there are people who are
becoming who describe themselves as
spiritual but not as denominational
right so here's the other numbers 79
agree that miracles still
occur today as in ancient times 68
believe that angels and demons are
active in the world
so first of all i was raised in a church
in which this is 100
the belief right so i was raised an idea
that that
as a kid who sat during pastor beam and
beemer's sermons and read the book of
revelation over and over again right a
world a demon for old world is not that
strange but 70 of americans believe in
angels and demons that might match with
some of you but it's way higher than
others
so if we are live in a world with our
fellow american citizens and 70 of them
believe that demons are active in the
world then where do we say what are the
weird things
right
if we live in a world where
you can say well
such and such
number of percentage of americans said
this thing that you go well i can't
believe it and then the newscaster said
but remember 70 of us believe in demons
you suddenly go like well okay
like so in other words
oftentimes this is not the world that
american historians teach to we don't
teach to a world in which
we think of a world of enlightenment
scholars who are only looking at
rational evidence but 70 percent of us
if we take this number at all legitimate
maybe it's less but what number of
people believing in demons is high
enough that you have to say when we're
talking about evidentiary discussions
we might be not be talking about the
world we think of right um
believe that houses can be haunted
55. 60. but the funny thing is i'll give
you the numbers in the interest of time
right so 37 of americans believe houses
can be haunted i will tell you that when
i ask my students they spike the graph
on haunted houses
for some reason the group of 18 to 21
are 100 down for haunted houses right 25
in astrology and this is a 2005 gallup
survey i'd like to see it it's not as
big as the other one so the numbers
might have some more fungibility 24 that
extraterrestrial beings have visited
earth at some time in the past 21 that
people can hear from or communicate
mentally with someone who has died 21
believe in witches my sense is that this
is not wiccans and the idea that there
are people who are practicing witches
but actually which is in the salem
converting with the dark arts sense but
remember popular culture is absolutely
full of this to the brim
in a sense that we say it's fiction but
clearly it's having an effect or maybe
that's not what it is it's long-standing
folk beliefs or whatever but we're
talking about a world in which forty
percent believe in haunted houses
seventy percent believe in angels and
demons right it is hard at some point
that i've said in a previous talk in a
different context it's hard not to think
that we're living in a medieval world
with high-speed internet
right
that we want to think that like these
things don't exist because we're in a
modern world and we have rockets well
yes we have rockets and we've invented
the internet which is a magical device
that puts all of human in
all of human knowledge at our fingertips
and we can share it worldwide with a
single touch of a single button and what
i want to send out it is my experience
with a demon
right
that what we the experiences we have the
world that we actually live in our
fellow americans maybe not people in
this room maybe people in this room
is a much more mystical filled world
than we want to often think of when
we're talking about engaging with other
people right
nearly half this is believed that it was
very likely or somewhat likely the u.s
air force is withholding proof of the
existence of intelligent life from other
planets more than half believe that ci
allowed drug dealers from central
america to sell crack cocaine to african
americans and u.s inner cities we're
going to talk about this a little bit
more when we talk about the racial
differences in conspiracy theories right
yes did i miss the percentage
of christ
no um that was a different
um survey that wasn't up here so the
number of believe christ will return
before 2050 the reason it is before 2050
is it was asked in 2010 by pew and the
question said in the next 40 years and
the reason it is structured that way is
to separate those people if you are in
southern baptist church of the nazarene
faiths that have a strong component of
the second coming of christ like i was
raised in and other ones there's a large
number of do that that is will that
eventually happen of course but this was
to say in my lifetime is this an event
that i do my life
thinking of my life forward with the
expectation that christ would appear in
the next 40 years so in other words am i
not doing my estate planning might be a
little different right
so
the number is 41
it was a pre-research of only 1500
adults so those numbers are a little
more fuzzy right
um 36 this is a 2012 nat geo survey 36
believe that ufos exist but 79 believe
the government is keeping information
about ufos from the public right so you
can ask someone and i don't know exactly
how these numbers work remember the
phrasing of questions can always bring
up different things you try to phrase a
question people read it a different way
but
it is not beyond what we have talked
about today to think in the first place
i don't think ufos exist but i
definitely believe the federal
government is covering up information
about it because if you ask me the
question is the government covering up
yes
right so even if i think it's not exist
they're covering up the non-existence of
this right 55 believe men in black or
other government agents threaten
witnesses of ufos even though only 36
believe that ufos exist
yes
my grandparents always pick up the phone
and will
listen through the entire survey but my
parents are too busy and hang up and so
i wonder out of this these surveys
you're right i mean i think there's i
don't know exactly in 2007 how they did
it i know that they tried to adjust for
age across the spectrum of the people
that survey i would feel pretty good
about the numbers the other ones
probably less so so the numbers can be a
little fungible but i'm in that group if
i don't recognize the number that's
calling me my phone might as well not
even have a ringer on it so i understand
yeah i don't know i mean and so i think
we always take these with with a little
bit of salt if you want to really lean
on one of these figures you'd want to
get deeper into the woods i i wanted to
set kind of parameters of what we we
think but you're right it's a great
question and particularly as you move
more and more modern the degree to which
there are not even landlines so it
changes
you have questions yeah
i know a lot of times we put it in the
dichotomy of we are becoming a more
secular people or more religious people
is it not possible to say that it's just
both and then it's just we're diverging
as a culturally yeah i don't i mean i
think that there's i think there's
evidence that we're becoming a less
churched people
or less traditionally church people in
the sense of denominational attachment
but i don't see there's any lack of
i mean the idea that we're becoming
secular in the sense that we're becoming
rational enlightenment figures that
voltaire would have imagined i don't see
that at all now for better or worse
right so i don't know is that related to
the lack of churchiness
church people does that like relate to
i'm i'm not going to go to my pastor
who's somebody i have a relationship
with i'm going to go to the internet
where i have a relationship um
yeah i don't know i mean i think i mean
i think
i
it would not take me much to start me
speculating but i think it would just be
that priest you know and
he was a good guy and he surely believed
in angels i did not but i trusted him on
other things you know what i mean yeah
and i'm so i don't know i don't know and
again i don't know how all of those
things would affect all these beliefs my
argument again i don't think any of
these questions are bad
are
i think these are great questions but
there is a sense what i want to
establish is
when we want to make conclusions that a
conspiracy seems ridiculous we need to
put in the context of what americans
actually believe and the boundaries of
what they actually believe are much
wider and much more
um
you know for someone who wants to think
that the
we're all about rational discourse a lot
scarier in a sense that what people
believe are things in which that the
boundaries of belief are far wider than
we want to
accept um so this is some information
they book american joseph visinsky and
joseph parent have done a book called
american conspiracy theories where they
did questionnaires published in 2014 an
exam extensive survey about conspiracy
belief they also examined 100 000
letters to the editor published between
1890 and 2010 to get a sense of a place
where people were publicly talking about
different conspiracies
and what they have argued is that
there's a conspiratorial dimension in
american society a group of people who
believe in conspiracies and think think
conspiratorially but are not relegated
to one political
racial or social group so what they've
done is they've sent out in trying to
get people's responses to this set of
questions to begin to classify them
a baseline set of openness to
conspiratorial thinking by asking a
series of questions that separates those
who are inclined to conspiracy belief
from those who aren't question one much
of the news we get from mainstream news
sources is deliberately slanted to
mislead us
51 percent strongly agree or agree 17
strongly disagree or agree much of our
lives are being controlled by plots
hatched in secret places
the occult them they
they lie to us even though we live in a
democracy a few people always run things
anyway which had 63 percent agree or
strongly agree the people who really run
the country are not known to the voters
50 agree or strongly agree so they use
these answer to these questions and
others to break out these people who are
higher on the conspiracy dimension and
lower on the others in other words so
they give these and based on all of
these answers being indexed you come out
as either low medium or high then the
question was to look at the demographics
of those people to see whether the high
group for example falls along the lines
that we would imagine midwestern who's
age 28 and his name phil and he's on the
internet he lives in his parents
basement right how specific can you get
on figuring out exactly who this guy
these people are and here's what they
found right
so the measure of strong of
conspiratorial dispositions this is the
whole group right so
um
to
control in secret places is 10 percent
agree
somewhat
strongly agree to a few people run
things people who run the country agree
is the strongest for all of those
questions that i presented to you and
then it drops down so this is just to
tell you that
of all of them you know controlled in
secret places the one that has the most
strongest neither strong or disagree but
just that how these things are
distributed according to these questions
this isn't getting us yet to the
demography right
gender male versus female
low about even medium female is slightly
higher in medium and then men are
slightly higher and high so in high
there are slightly few a few more men
than women in medium there's slightly a
few more women than men but by and large
the thing that stands out here is that
the gender distribution is almost 50 50.
so immediately our thought that this is
only a male phenomenon
then needs to be revised as does i think
your question is even better then where
are the female leaders is a really great
question where are the women because
when you look at studies of these
communities they are really focusing on
men and i think that's a missing piece
in this puzzle if we accept that the
numbers are closer to 50 50. right
um education
so
among people with no high school it is
the highest
right but it's 40 among high school
graduates it's almost 40
college degrees it's 30 percent and
postgraduate it's 25. now depending on
whether you think the difference between
40 and 25 is really large or
surprisingly small
this number is not overwhelming in the
sense that once you get a college degree
it disappears
you're 30
30 of people in their survey with
college degrees or some college are
still high on the index of believing
these conspiracies right so that
certainly education has an effect
that the less education there's a chance
of being higher but not nearly as big as
you would imagine right and that
postgraduate has the most number of
people who are low
for a variety of reasons or socialized
into kind of enlightenment thinking and
problem solving and use of evidence or
whatever
but again the numbers across the board
show that education matters it is a big
effect but it's not the overwhelming
effect in which you'd say as you go up
this number drops to five or ten percent
okay
um more of their findings very
surprising political ideology
strongly democrat or strongly very
liberal or very conservative and party
affiliation strong democrat or strong
republican does not have a very high
effect right people with high levels on
the conspiracy dimension raised between
24 and 40 percent on the democratic side
and 27 and 33 on the republican side in
fact the highest rates perhaps
unsurprisingly are among independents
because people who have rejected both
parties as being tools of whatever are
not effective for a variety of reasons
are independent they have the highest
levels but it is not a sense that it is
right wingers who were only involved in
conspiracy thinking according to the way
they're studying it
it does change very much who is involved
in the conspiracies
that people on the right wing are
looking at conservatives are looking at
communists they're looking at socialists
people on the left wing are looking at
corporations
halliburton et cetera et cetera so the
people they're picking for their
conspiracies are very different but the
degree to which they're willing to
believe in conspiracies that that in
other words
right-wing left-wing democrat republican
they all have a secret room where they
are meeting to do things we don't like
but the membership list and the name
cards on the seats in the secret room
are completely different
right
george soros versus dick cheney
right you have very different people
depending on which side right those on
the high on the index are less likely to
vote or give money which is probably not
surprisingly more likely to be
generixers than millennials
that my generation those born in the
late 60s and 70s are more likely to be
believe in conspiracies than millennials
who were born later that might change as
they get older who knows
slightly more inclined to violence this
is a big question as to whether
conspiracy people who believe in
conspiracies are more inclined to
violence
slightly
they answered the question violence is
sometimes an acceptable way to show
disapproval of the government sixteen
percent of people on the high end said
yes eleven percent of medium six percent
of low
so if you believe in conspiracies there
is a higher chance of committing
violence
or no maybe not committing higher level
chance of believing violence is a
legitimate way to show disfavor to the
government
but not in a way that's that's
for me overwhelmingly different 16 to 11
right
so
obama not born in the united states is
the red
9 11 conspiracy in the federal
government in the blue right this is
2006 maybe it's changed since then the
interesting thing is both conspiracies
are believed by wide numbers of
americans different americans that the
democrats 40 plus percent believe that
the 911 was a conspiracy in the federal
government
much lower among
between among republicans and then obama
not born in the united states is
surprisingly
very low among democrats and very high
among republicans
so in the sense what repub what
political party does
is tell you
staff the villains differently and
choose which conservative which
conspiracies you're scared of
but not necessarily whether you'll
believe in conspiracies at all
what if any role does religion play in
whether someone believes in conspiracy
looking at the questions that we looked
at in terms of what americans said
so many of them are religious based
so i'm wondering whether
either
i am not sure that i have seen and
there's a great question i'm not sure
i've seen any of the people who are
asking conspiracy theories i don't have
or know the numbers
that i've seen that are telling me if
i'm catholic i'm much more likely to
believe in conspiracies because these
people are not asking religious
questions and the people are asking the
pew study on religion or not asking
about conspiracies so i'm bringing these
two groups together but they haven't
been indexed in a way that they really
need to be because that's a really great
question
so this is a comment related to the
gender thing i did some googling
and i found an article on gq that was
like the 10 sexiest women that you
didn't know were conspiracy theorists
so i went through it
and it's all like
the themes that i saw were
aliens mermaids astrology and
anti-vaxxers
not political right so i that was like
so after you showed like statistics of
like oh well there's more likely to be
like it's 50 50.
i think maybe considering like
what conspiracy theories women think
it's a great idea to be involved in
that's a great idea and then in the
sense that i also think
vaccination might be one of the center
yeah rings of that it's a really great
that's a really great point yeah so it's
not just again it might be that gender
not just poli they're looking they're
political scientists right so we're
looking at political breakdown and how
that affects conspiracy belief i think
if you looked at gender what you might
find is not
less or more but the particular
conspiracies that they are interested in
might be different
according to their gender i mean you
want to not be so gender essentialist
about it but you want to check those
numbers and look at them so that's a
great point thank you for googling
which groups are conspiring right for
democrats it's corporations and
conservatives for republicans it's
liberals and communists
to the degree that those are different
things in the minds of some
conservatives
yeah
yeah i've gotten slightly confused now
about like conspiracy does it have to be
conducted secretly and i'm thinking
about some like
people like myself who believe that the
wealthy and powerful work in ways that
are obvious yeah but dishonest is that a
i don't know
i would want to put you on the couch and
have you talk me through it
i'd say no i mean right so i mean again
this is the what we started with before
that conspiracies exist right okay we
know that the at bohemian grove or we
know at bilderberg or the or do you win
powerful people meet behind closed doors
and talk and we can look at it and say
this seems unfair that the system
structurally economically they have is
rigged against certain people and
rewards other people but does unfair
signal conspiracy that's and i'm no in
my own thought i wouldn't think so i
mean i think there's a way in which
politics is the dividing up of the goods
and services in a in a particular
political group and they go to some
people and don't go to others i think
there's a point where that moves into
conspiracy but i don't think on its face
it is okay yeah good no good question um
so
a political sign they argue the
conspiracy theorists follow political
logic this is a way for groups falling
in the pecking order to revamp
themselves to explain losses close ranks
this is trump saying
it's going to get stolen from me and
he's preparing people on the right side
to the defeat at the hands of clinton
and setting up that it was a conspiracy
that has taken it from him to kind of
pre-prepare for how you'll handle a loss
right so they argue that the big factors
are asymmetries and political power
generally linked to who has the white
house and that is would be your
explanation right for 9 11. 9 11 happens
with a republican president and the
perception is this is a
republican conspiracy to have a war in
the middle east
had obama or had gorban sitting in that
office my guess is the read according to
them would been completely different
right that whoever was sitting in the
chair the other team is going to accuse
them of something so this is a way in
which
if there's not if there's a if there's
not a foreign threat the most
overwhelming thing is political
uh changes in who has power and
domestically democrats who has the white
house generally
or republicans right
so when obama goes into office all of a
sudden
left-wing complaints about corporations
and the right wing drop
right when trump goes into office
concern about george soros and the power
of socialist is going to
drop right that they engage as political
power shifts now i think this is
somewhat too simple i don't think it
explains everything i don't think it
handles all of the conspiracies that
move beyond political but it is worth
thinking about particularly because
we're at the 911 museum which is not
only
but certainly in a large part a
political conspiracy okay
had we been talking about different
conspiracies this information might be
less if we're talking about ufos for
example still might be interesting to
think
the way the the widespread belief and
who the conspiracy theorists are but
this is much more a kind of them
political scientists not surprisingly
looking at political questions right
following this theory the fact that
glenn beck if you remember glenn beck's
show when i was teaching a conspiracy
class glenn beck was must see tv as you
just take clips and bring them into
class right so in 2008 he gets a show
there's a lot of conspiracy theory a lot
of george soros and gold and different
things and that for their argument of
course obama wins the the the field is
ripe for a kind of conspiracy theories
particularly aiming at socialist and
concerned communists and then when
republicans take the house in 2010
beck's popularity goes down there's less
of a need of this the panic over obama's
victory is lower
so they would argue that the political
domestic shifts explain that change
right there might be other issues as
well right
so this is also the reason why jfk stays
so popular jfk is the perfect conspiracy
for politics because
depending on where you sit politically
you can always find your bad guys in the
room
if you are
right if you want a foreign threat it's
soviet or it's cuban if you are
concerned about the right wing then they
are cia agents military corporations
bell helicopter in oliver stones movie
right or if you're right-wing and you're
concerned about someone on the left
having killed kennedy then they're
communist they're pro-castro they're
literally soviets right so as well as
mobsters in case you want a wild card
so because of the number of attacks that
people the number of different theories
about kennedy it spans across the
spectrum i mean this is from the
internet obviously which is i tried to
issue interest-free money into the
system so the american people wouldn't
be enslaved by the banking cartel and
the federal reserve had me killed
so even if you don't want to do left
right communist capitalist military
contractors cia agents mobsters if you
run through that and you don't like any
of those you can turn to the fed
as the one who really killed kennedy
because he was going to introduce
silver-backed money right
um there are racial differences right
there are many conspiracies that center
around the relationship between
african-americans and white society and
again as dick is brought up as we talked
about this should not be
surprising given the history of white
supremacy and racial oppression of
non-white groups in this country given
the number of things that were done to
them purely legally whether it is jim
crow segregation or slavery for 400
years the idea that the american
government is working against the
interests of african americans latinx
and other people of color is not
surprising
the numbers we'll look at in a second
but one again the changes are not
necessarily the interest and
conspiracies but what the conspiracies
are the belief that the crack epidemic
of the 1990s was the cia plot coming out
of
gary webb's working in the san jose
mercury news
the idea that age was invented in a
government lab to eliminate the black
race
again you would like to say
the american government would not do
that i would like to believe i do
believe the american government would
not do that but you also have the
tuskegee syphilis experiment you have a
long history of medical experience
experiments and things being done to
african-american populations in which it
makes it very hard to say that is
categorically untrue i think it's untrue
i don't think it makes sense it seems
like a
awkward disease to release into for
various reasons it isn't going to be
effective but i also think the fact that
i'm actually talking about the logistics
of doing it means that i've already lost
the moral argument that it's impossible
that it could have happened right the
idea that the levees in new orleans and
new orleans were purposely destroyed
after hurricane katrina to flood the
ninth ward majority african-american and
spare majority white sections of the
city right now these ideas are not
exclusively held by african americans
but among african americans there are
different conspiracies that come out
directly of the african-american
experience right things in which
i mean arguably i imagine that people in
the gay community could look at aids as
a kind of a right-wing plan to get rid
of homosexuals right so it's possible to
imagine another using some of these
pieces to come up with a different
conspiracy but that is not one that
necessarily is plaguing middle class
america right
this is race and conspiratorial just
predispositions among whites this is low
is that 36 percent high is about 30
percent and medium is about 35 among
african americans it's about 20 percent
for low so fewer on the low end many
more on the high end almost 45 percent
and then uh in the medium and then high
is about 30 percent so the high is not
that much different among the races
again it's not and then this is hispanic
down here non-white hispanic right so in
which medium is very high so more people
in the black community are open to these
they rank in the medium or high but on
the high level it's not exclusively
higher for african americans or
what they have as hispanic or latinx
versus white right
um so here you have right spike lee and
he's on bill maher in 2007. so it's not
far for far-fetched a choice had to be
made to save one neighborhood flood
another neighborhood look if we're in la
and there's an emergency situation we
call from beverly hills or we call from
compton which one are the cops coming to
first do you think the 2000 election was
fair if they can rig an election they
can do anything with the history in this
country you ever heard of the tuskegee
experiments there are many examples if
we go down the line where stuff like
this happen to african-american people i
don't put anything past the american
government when it comes to people of
color right so in this one statement
spike lee is moving through a number of
things we've discussed tonight as far as
saying as an african-american male who's
familiar with the history of the
american people and the african-american
people with the american government
there are a number of things right one
structural racism we don't get the kind
of social services that we get two you
have to make a decision to flood one
neighborhood and of course the
african-americans are going to come out
on the bad end of that and the tuskegee
experiments just to put in there
don't tell me the government wouldn't do
this
right
so and then in the middle do you think
the 2000 election was fair if they can
rig an election they can do anything
again there is this and you could if you
change the names dates people places but
kept all of this talking about they with
a different set of evidence it could
work for people of different races right
but these are distinct because of the
experience of african americans inside
of the united states that make sense
right
i just made a quick connection to um
what we talked about earlier if 36
believe ufos exist but 79 believe the
government's keeping information
away from about that so it's kind of
like well i don't know that i believe in
ufos but if there is it wouldn't
surprise me that it's being kept a
secret and isn't that the same kind of
yeah i mean i think there's there is a
kind of a there's a long history among
understandably among in the
african-american population of all the
things that have been done and it's
impossible to say that it couldn't be
done yeah i mean it's right so i i mean
absolutely right where do we start with
like kyrie
the basketball player in flat earth they
lie to us on the back of a kid's jersey
right trust no one yeah
so
i guess
i find it problematic to
compare
you know events where there is evidence
like
like these like the tuskegee experiment
sure the eugenics movement i mean
there's
lots of examples right right
to belief in ufos
i i don't see it as a single i i think
that's right i mean i i understand that
what i guess i wanted to say is the
argument here in which
and i think that
if you want to look at what has been
done and i'm not necessarily saying this
is the same as ufo belief but i am
saying that there is that this is
conspiratorial belief about politics and
the arguments that he's making is one in
which we can't trust the government the
government acts against this number has
done these things
yeah
oh yeah sure yeah
you know
society sure
that that this and again and because i
am a person of color i will tend to
believe sure the these kinds of
statements
um
because like even the eugenics movement
wasn't just people of color was poor
people sure right if you're poor
regardless of what color you are in this
country
many things have happened where
government where the government has made
certain decisions or or just absolutely
discounted the rights and the the
humanity of the people being affected
and so
absolutely
well i guess the difference would be
that in our kind of first conversation
which is these things are revealed to
have actually occurred and it kind of
goes into like nick's thing which is
there are things that are done that we
know are done that are wrong in evil
that aren't conspiracies so some of
these certainly fall into that but this
is also the basis of
uh
is age designed in a lab this same
rationale like you said the rationale
for here is somewhat easier to buy
because they're talking about things
that actually occurred some of those
other beliefs this is going to be the
evidence the proof text for that in the
same way
similar ways if not as believable
for other conspiracies are going to draw
on what the american government has done
more generally yeah what's interesting
to me is that
the
and this is from an english teacher
the rhetorical moves the rhetoric is the
same even though the experience
is absolutely different as you said and
absolutely accurately evidence-based
based on history but because is it fair
to say that because the the
rhetoric is the same the rhetorical
moves the moves of argument
that these are both conspiracy theories
well i think it's interesting so exactly
we go to this right so dark alliance was
1996 gary webb writing about he won a
policy with a poster prize-winning
journalist writing in the san jose
mercury news wrote a series of articles
arguing that during the iran contra plot
cia agents looked the other way or
actually assisted central american drug
cartels linked to right-wing movements
the press argue
attacked him for argument that ca
started the crack epidemic now it wasn't
exactly what he said he didn't say
necessarily he wasn't even arguing that
the cia was bringing in the crack and
selling it on the streets as much as
they were aligned with people who were
selling drugs to finance their
paramilitary activities and the cia
looked the other way
now so the question is is this true or
not i mean it's hard to imagine saying
again we'd love to say the us government
wouldn't do this i actually think
there's a really strong argument that
the claims of african-american people in
particular latino people as well
their claims that are legitimate are
dismissed as conspiracies because they
sound like the other conspiracies right
so i think that there is a sense in
which
you can attack spike lee or ignore spike
lee and say flooding the ninth ward or
medical experiments or tuskegee like at
some point in tuskegee if that had come
out in the late 60s as an accusation
people would have said that's absolutely
100 not true it can't be true it's a
crazy conspiracy theory right so i
actually think that one of the other
angles is that when spike lee sounds
like in many cases
other like if you change these words it
sounds like it then legitimate
complaints of african americans and
people of color are rejected as
conspiracy theories when in fact they
will be proved not to have been
right
so
so how does conspiracy thinking work and
this is slightly different getting from
the
getting into the idea of moves and
rhetoric right language of symbols
you'll see a if you read conspiracy
stuff or see conspiracies talk they will
show symbols talk about symbols the
importance of symbols the obsessions
with numbers and dates right if you're
going to make and i make my class my
team my students make a conspiracy and
to see whether they've mastered this
kind of language right the idea that
roswell and the cia are both founded in
47 right that's going to be one the fact
that the american revolution and the
illuminati are both in 1776 right you're
going to draw these connections
i believe in long-lived secret
conspiracies often of groups and
families big elements of racism and
anti-semitism anti-semitism jewish
bankers are alive and well that is a big
rhetoric big background move
anti-semitism rears its head often seen
as connections to biblical or other
ancient groups sometimes it is
the masons if they count they claim to
be connected to king solomon um to bible
to ancient astronauts to
the
uh the templars come up a lot of these
ancient groups that are tied into it or
that this is part of a long understood
biblical luciferian plot right and often
i want to talk about this it's key to
keystone thoughts that are not obvious
in the conspiracy itself we have one
more we have a question
um
and one of the things i want to say is
there are no coincidences
there are no coincidences this is
probably the most powerful thing of
thinking about conspiratorial thought if
something happens on a day that is
related to another event it must be
connected it is impossible that
the ufos and the cia are not connected
right there are no coincidences because
the many of the conspiratorial thinking
is if there are two things much
conspiratory thinking is simply did you
know that blank and blank
right so did you know that two and six
i'm not adding it up i'm not telling you
what it is i'm just saying doesn't it
seem a little weird that seven and four
and four
right so you'll see this again and again
the rationale of saying i'm putting two
things together and i'm not causally
linking them but doesn't it seem strange
that this symbol is on both things
right
so
in an american i also want to say this
is where we get into some religion
because
i was raised in an end times church it
doesn't surprise me but it is rife and
american culture remember that hashtag
was talking about millennialism and
apocalyptic views right that often
conspiracy fears are connected to
christian eschatology christian
eschatology is the study of the end of
the world right the rapture the second
coming the tribulation all of these
kinds of things that involves numerology
and symbols right if you read the book
of revelation which is a key text for
this there are going to be
seven horns and nine crowns and so many
bowls and so many angels and so many
witnesses and saints and there's going
to be a dragon and a leopard right it's
all
symbolism it's all again remember the
occult idea the hidden this is a code to
be figured out to tell you what will
happen in the future and you need to
know who the dragon is and who is the
[ __ ] of babylon and what is the
antichrist all of these questions and if
you believe
in the kind of what has emerged as a how
lindsay um
end times right the left behind series
becomes a massive from 1995 to 2007 16
books 80 million copies the first four
left behind books have the four slots on
the top
on the new york times bestseller list at
the same time
seven have been number one five films
of differing quality and one pc game
right but this is popular culture and
the understanding remember that the
underlying argument of this kind of how
lindsay late great planet earth
revolution uh revelation thought is
there will be a world government
controlled by the antichrist
and it will persecute christians during
the tribulation so when they talk about
the u.n or they talk about the atf or
they talk about the new world order and
you want to argue particular bits of
this for some people
they're not arguing that evidence
because they know there will be a world
government okay maybe it's not the u.n
maybe it's the eu maybe it's something
else but you're trying to argue the
facts of a particular case but
underneath it is this belief of a
that we know there will be a world
government
you want to argue about whether it's
going to be agenda 21 as part of it or
not
but the real argument is
do we believe that the book of
revelation is telling a future story in
which there will be a world government
shared by the antichrist and we are in
the world time so it must be happening
soon
right if you believe the world christ
will come again in the next 40 years and
if this is the narrative of the future
then we're only waiting for the world to
get in line with what we know will occur
and so an argument about agenda 21 is
only a tiny bit of an argument of a
giant worldview that is often hidden
from view in the conversation that
you're having right
this is an illuminated reading of the
dollar how did we get
an eagle and so this is the obsession of
the 13 it could be the 13 colonies maybe
who knows right this is the 72 layers of
brick are tied into the 72 powers of the
name of god and the kabbalah
the we do have the all-seeing eye the
great architect who on this is listed as
lucifer
but it is strange right that on our
money like if you look at other
countries money
there are birds on it
right there's like
madame curie or like a poet and ours has
a masonic symbol of the all-seeing eye
right and again it happened roosevelt
who was a mason talked to harry uh one
of henry wallace who was his vice
president about redesigning the money
also a mason this is the great seal of
the united states
so this these two things are the either
side of the great sea of the united
states which never got much play but was
made in the 1770s by a bunch of masons
and it's now put on the money but
there's an argument that they will argue
that this money is a kind of magic spell
that the money looks like this for a
reason if someone is plotting and saying
there's a luciferian
masonic plot part of the united states
and they feature this right
then this is the argument of these are
the important symbolism right so and
i this i can't even i actually believe
right so you have people who are afraid
of the government
right you have people who are fear
afraid of the government afraid of
plots of parades of masonic plots
luciferian plots is that everyone
familiar with who john poindexter is
john poindexter was in
the
bush white house and was indicted and
convicted in 1991 in the iran contra
affair
found guilty later pardoned and he's
called back to head the darpa
information awareness office do you know
what darpa is
darpa is the defense advanced research
projects administration i think
it is the spookiest of the spooky it is
where the government makes its most
advanced pieces of technology it's a big
thing in conspiracies for
weather manipulation or chemtrails or
all of the other things if you need a
piece of tech that is on the edge of
scientific possibility darpa is your
office so it's already suspicious this
was he was head back to the information
awareness office is anyone where the
information awareness office was
supposed to be
this was the debate in 2002 over whether
the nsa would be legally able to collect
all of your communications on the
internet and all of your phone calls and
the internet the aware information
awareness office was the office that was
going to collect all of the electronics
communications there was a huge pushback
against it and this was shelved though
parts of it were put into other things
okay so this is a guy convicted in iran
contra comes back heading the office is
a military head of darpa or working with
darpa on the information awareness
office they have come up with a symbol
for this organization where they're
saying we're going to absorb all of your
information we're going to keep it but
trust us we'll be okay with it and i'm
john poindexter you can believe me i was
in iran contra okay
do you does anyone know the symbol they
picked for this organization
it is a floating all-seeing eye with a
beam coming onto the planet absorbing
all human knowledge
and then you wonder like you got to
think like you got to be trolling people
right
right you put
sciencia as potentia science's power
underneath a picture of a floating
masonic eye with its beam shooting down
on
i think europe i mean
right so
these were the olympic mascots in 2012
right
so you put that on top and you go like
they say it's a it's a cab light do you
think anyone concerned about the
watching the giant space pyramid is
think that's a cab light
but you're going to have the olympics
there and you're going to give them
one-eyed figures with pyramids on their
heads
right i mean so and i don't i don't
think this is an illuminati plot
but i mean you gotta think like come on
right
so
right so what are the appeals of these
beliefs right
one is there really is a deep pleasure
in figuring out what's happening and
what's in the know like this was there's
a lot of work done on the importance of
pt barnum in the night in the eight in
the 19th century
and part of the appeal of barnum the
buncombe the mystery come and see the
fiji mermaid was to go there and figure
it out this is the why we want to watch
a magician why we want to watch chris
angle part of it is we want
the idea of i'm going to figure out the
trick and this is on a bigger scale that
sense that you have in talking to so
many conspiracy theorists on a delta
flight
where they look at you and they say
you're fooled
i'm not fooled i know what's going on i
understand i'm not one of the sheep i've
figured it out i'm above the system i'm
i understand what's really going on in a
world of confusing complexity i have the
key i've unlocked it i know what cause
and effect is and how it works right
because
in reading a lot of these conspiracy
theories there is a real sense of fear
that no one is in control
right
the idea that even if there's a
conspiracy that's controlling everything
that's malicious that's evil that's
cruel at least someone's in control
i can see it in reading the kind of
writings of puritans in the in the 17th
century and the calvinist god is a mean
at times god but it's still that sense
of being in the hands of someone who's
in control even if there's an evil
conspiracy at least things aren't just
happening random we aren't just prince
of you know prisoner to one thing
bouncing into another or that 9 11 just
happened because it happened that way
right there has to be somebody behind it
and if somebody's behind it even if
that's not somebody you want to be in
charge the idea that the world is the
thing that can be controlled
and it's not random and someone's behind
it and there's a plot there's a purpose
there's a reason for this all even if
the reason's awful
is sometimes better for many of these
people than
the idea that's just random right
because also if there's someone in
control if the world the modern world
and all of its complexity is something
that can be controlled then we can
replace the person in control and put us
in charge or someone good in charge
someone can be in charge
and so there's something to fight
against if all of these things just
simply happen out of random happenstance
then
how do we improve
if there is a world that we can control
then we can fight against it and if we
fight against it we can win and this
thing is a thing that can be controlled
right
um many conspiracy theories as you talk
to them under overstate their ability to
explain things this is now when you're
in conversation with them such as
gravity or light
people want to have universal sets of
explanations it's easier it's more
comprehensive right if you say that all
of these things are are due to a
particular single factor it makes it
easier to understand right
often times and you will see this if you
are going to engage your students on
this they will give you and quote
information that has no basis in fact
but it will be quoted to you in a very
strong voice right
and part of this is american democracy
has always had a really uncomfortable
experience with experts
there is a strong part of our culture
that says i'm not going to listen to you
just because you are some expert or you
have a degree right there is this kind
of and again politicians play into this
all the time the elites the experts want
to tell you that you don't know such and
such but we should run our
our our economy our nation's economy the
same way you run a household economy
well that makes no sense
but to tell you a politician who says
you don't need to listen to the experts
you know
right i mean it's how many people are
like well yeah your cardiologist said
that but my naturologist said i should
do this and you think why should i
believe one rather than the other right
why should we believe someone simply
because they're an expert right
and this rejection of expertise is also
the sense that the evidence that they're
bringing to you is inherently tainted
right you can't trust it because they
lie to you well sure your cardiologist
said that but that's because the ama has
tried to get rid of natural medicine for
a hundred years so he's just part he's
just a pawn in this conspiracy
right
cultural theorist peter knight noted
that quote conspiracy had become the
default assumption in an age which has
learned to distrust everything and
everyone i think tamara was here and
said as a millennial all of this stuff
is literally the language that she
speaks she doesn't even need to talk
about it or have language because the
images that you see the memes simply
communicate all of the information
because she's so kind of
like
involved in this culture this way
right and the actions of government have
as we've talked about throughout the day
have led to more of these even the
attempts to be transparent
have led to the assumption of more
conspiracies right
um
so one of these things that you see in
these conspiracies as you get into them
and you engage with them is that they
escalate they find themselves escalating
the plot uh in 9 11 for example for a
person who says well who has to be in on
it
well there weren't actually planes those
were missiles well what happened to the
actual planes with actual passengers
well they were taken
okay so now everyone at this airfield is
also involved in what they were just
murdered there i mean like so you get
these theories as they move out you have
to have more and more people involved in
them to have the the the moon hoax
right
you have to have all of these people not
only at the time in nasa but then since
and then all the people in government
and all the people who've covered it up
after that and all of the astronauts and
people who worked in nasa after that and
all the people that gets bigger and
bigger and bigger right all the
logistics of hiding planes of hiding of
911 faking the moon landing the flat
earth is
huge on this right i mean to hide the
fact that the earth is flat
and that we're sending satellites up
that aren't going anywhere but it's all
part of a conspiracy to cover it up
oftentimes lead to magical and
supernatural right you reach a point
where the evidence is going to begin to
collapse and what you see underneath
that is clearly
a religious
or magical sense that this can happen
because the rules of reality are not the
ones by which we're having this
discussion right
and this sense of no coincidence is when
someone introduces something and says
well isn't it weird that
this data point is there right isn't it
weird like and you know i'm sure
no one knows them better than me that
there are data points of the entire 11
that no even says to go like yes that's
weird like that's a strange thing that
it happened that way
but the conspiracy theorist doesn't
there's no room for that right this is
all a system in which things are being
done for particular reasons and there
are no coincidences right
again as we said 911 as an inside job
brings this all the time which is
why did this happen this way why did it
occur this way and engaging with people
the plot often gets bigger and bigger
and the cover-up has to get huger and
huger and more and more people who have
somehow stayed silent have to be part of
it
as it expands right
these um
as you might imagine on the internet in
particular these conspiracies can be
very unstable communities right
passionate communities of people who
feel that they are discovering the
essential truth about the world
they're drawn together by their sense
that they're finding a real truth and
that they share this persecution
they want to have an interest to battle
the conspiracy
but they are also fragile communities
and very explosive right because with an
inability to control how evidence works
there's no way to change and how do you
fight battles over where the boundaries
of the conspiracy are so someone has a
conspiracy about the cia doing something
and someone brings in ufos
and you go i don't want ufos in my
political conspiracy well you're hiding
then you're part of the conspiracy
because it's all about ufos right so
someone brings in an element of
some other aspect right so you're
arguing about um
you you're arguing about cia and then
they bring in well it's because they're
working as david ike says with the
underground lizard people and someone
goes okay look we don't want underground
lizard people in our conspiracy we want
you out and the thought is
by what by what metric right we've moved
past the idea where we're introducing
rational evidence and having like how do
we make these choices so we're in a
community and i introduce that david
david ike's ideas of a reptilian race or
i introduce
graze into the conversation and it can
rapidly spin out of control now i want
to show you just a little bit about that
this is oh look nazi nazi flat earthers
aren't you surprised
this was an article on wonkette
that's very snarky but it illustrates
this in which there is on stormfront
which is a nazi page
dedicated to
the hoaxer cost the holocaust not being
real and white supremacy in aryan
nations there was a strong influx of
flat earthers who wanted addressed that
the flat earth was part of this
conversation and then you watched the
there's white liberty the guy who
posting who says science is the
acquisition of knowledge capable of
being reproduced you can't reproduce big
bang it's not science with flat earth
there are multiple lines of evidence
that point in the same direction
uh many globe claims have been power of
suggestion reliance on authority you
can't land on a lightning bolt you can't
land on the sun or stars or planets if
they are electromagnetic plasma
formations we don't normally deal with
plasma or understand its properties
right so now this would this would
explain why nasa had to lie and fake a
moon mission so now you have flat earth
coming into this community of
nazi aryan nations people right so then
it goes this guy writes why not they lie
about the holocaust they lie about the
bible they lie about the single war they
constantly change history they pretend
to be part of the european diaspora they
lie about the control that banks have
they shovel race mixing propaganda down
our throats so if any of this flat earth
stiff has any merit at all it wouldn't
be a surprise if the jews were lying
about that too
so now you have a conspiracy movement
now i don't feel bad for storm front
right so weep not for the nazis but this
isn't our i honestly i do believe the
moonlight landings are fake i don't
think we can even get to the moon nasa
even admitted we can't get past the van
allen belt due to radiation so i'm 100
the moon landings were faked
at least the first one
so i mean so you think like again
this is not meant for probably a deep
dive but you would like to know so the
van allen belts mean you can't leave the
atmosphere
so we faked the first one
but then maybe not the other ones right
so again but what so i mean so you have
this like wire so then you have other
nazis come in and argue back and forth
about you need to get out of here so you
have these conspiracy movements and
again the question about the internet
they bloom they grow they move they
separate out and then they go and they
fester and they grow and they grow again
now again i don't mean to use festive
overly pejorative i mean some of these
people are people looking for real
evidence who are really concerned that
their kid got autism and they're
concerned that it's vaccines whether you
think they're misguided or not they're
not necessarily evil that is not the
place for necessary aryan nations but
right the difficulty of debate is that
you are when you have a student or you
have a person on your delta flight that
you're having this conversation with
it's hard when the two sides rega regard
each other as naive or stupid or worse
corrupt
like you're part of this
system right
they off conspiracy believers often have
a considerable amount of evidence
that may or may not be true but they
have mastered it and it will come at you
in rapid-fire fashion
so the difficulty of engaging with
evidence that may or may not be true
often referred to as a quantity of
evidence over a quality of logic right
and you're having these conversations
with your students you will
i will venture a guess as because when
they are 18 in my classroom i am shocked
at the amount of information they can
master about a conspiracy theory and
shoot out with 100 confidence and be
unable to tell me anything about the
constitution right so so they are they
are skilled in particular areas right
so again these are often ideas that are
closer to identity or or religion so
moving forward
and just attempting to say you're dumb
you're wrong
is not necessarily going to generate a
dialogue that's going to influence
anybody right
so
i've had to find other ways to engage
this since i am walking headfirst into
this debate um
oh so so for example this is the flat
earth we've talked about behind the flat
earth
is a religious concept
oftentimes now i don't know that kyrie
irving is particularly this which is
that the bible talks about the way that
the earth was set up that it has a
firmament that it has pillars set in
that there is a a depth underneath
that's where the leviathan swims and so
one of the underlying things about flat
earth that seems so ridiculous and so
like well we know that the flat earth
could be a picture of it or if there was
if the earth was flat gravity would work
in a horribly strange way in which trees
on the edge would all point to the
center because of where the gravity well
would be we think we haven't really
worked out the math of a flat earth
gravity system
but underneath that is about biblical
literalism about the bible being true
and having a debate over whether
how satellites would work is not nearly
as important as the idea that the bible
is true and the bible tells me this and
the reason this is being covered up is
because
modern american society hates the bible
and wants to convince people the bible
isn't true with this idea of a round
earth
right so
the debate over the flat earth seems
like the easiest debate in the world to
win that it would this is literally
going to take no time but underneath it
is often times deeper issues of identity
and belief that aren't attached to that
argument
yeah
question
yep that's coming
so i want to go back to my question
about like measuring religious
affiliation or beliefs because i feel
like all of these examples in some way
connect to some religious component
and so
like
how like it how is this like
could you study this measuring what
someone's
religious beliefs are
because i feel like
in every single one of these there's
some level of like
reference to the bible or anti-semitism
in some way there's a religious
component right so if you take like the
religion out of it you look at cultures
or societies that are not affiliated in
any way with that like what how is that
no i think it could be a really
interesting study that i haven't done to
look at
there are certainly societies in europe
for example that are much less religious
and much less even spiritual in their
belief than ours to look at whether
their conspiracies have these same
components i think it's a great idea no
i agree with you i think it's a
wonderful question
um
so i wanted to respond to that and also
like
so because a claim that you made earlier
about like religious claims being safe
from evidentiary arguments
i think that's only really true if you
talk about traditional christianity
because i mean this like people like
yeah like muslim ever so why like then
it's like well why does everyone think
that muslims are terrorists
when you know it's like their religion
tells them to be
like
loving and kind and like all of these
things and then everyone's trying to
like go back to the quran be like but
here it says like there's this one
sentence that like it says talks about
killing people and like there's
sentences in the bible where it talks
about that too so i think we talk about
what religions are safe from evidentiary
arguments i think there's a distinction
there i guess what i meant was in
personal conversation if someone says
that they believe something that's
religious
the response
tends to be among if someone says i
believe jfk was shot by the mob that is
a conversation we can have that seems
evidentiary and if you say
i believe in jesus as my personal savior
i don't feel the sense that you have
opened a conversation about evidence now
i will also say that you're right in the
sense that people from outside of a
religion will look at things inside of a
religion to justify their prejudices
against that religion but as you said
for muslim in particular you know what
is what is the struggle right i mean so
what is what are we talking about to
what degree can you look at something
that advocates violence and there's
things certainly in the bible that's a
very violent book particularly in the
old testament right so but i think what
i mean about the eventually claims is we
tend to give
socially a free path to religious claims
that we don't hold them up in the same
way as factual claims right
but i i think so
if someone says like oh like i believe
in allah then it's like
oh my god so you're gonna like i don't
know everyone i don't think everyone
reacts that way but yeah i certainly
understand yeah there's an underlying
thing
sure jump in here
that maybe using the term religion
can get us hung up because i think one
of the most important things that steve
is talking about here
is the notion that we still
have an enchanted world a world that is
full of all kinds of powers
visible invisible
go back
guys to to my talk on oklahoma city
right when i said to you
that for
many people in oklahoma city the bombing
ripped away
particularly for conservative
evangelicals the bombing rips away this
illusion of secularity and behind it
there is this teeming world
of
angels and other angel the presence of
angels was everywhere
uh in in
the culture of the time right uh angels
bringing the children up to heaven i
mentioned to you the newspaper with
uh shimmering insulation and people
drawing
lines to angels so this notion
you know of an enchanted world with all
these powers is
is really really important and it's not
so hard for us to think about we don't
think all space in all time is the same
right they're are powerful places sacred
places sacred times
a good and simple but not simplistic
definition of say sacred space any place
that's capable of being defiled or
desecrated is by definition sacred we
don't think about a parking lot at a
supermarket in the same way we think
about gettysburg
or
the space here
um so i think that's a really really
important
part of all of this um and one other
just thing i was thinking about
um i've heard
steve do this
lecture now it gets bitter every time
and i
i keep falling in the trap saying boy i
i'm really glad i can sit back and
think rationally and above
conspiratorial thinking and then i think
of the conversations that we both have
about the kennedy assassination
and i believe that oswald acted but
didn't act alone um
so there we are but even more
conspiracy theory as a
kind of
behavioral reflexive tick
that we have uh maybe as americans maybe
simple example and i just thought about
this today where you're talking um
your sports team loses
an agonizing game
well they probably really didn't lose
the refs lost it
there was a conspiracy because the
conference wants
x team to win so they can make all the
money i read this all the time on sports
blogs and
i
i do it myself
they shouldn't have lost that game i bet
that ref was secretly you know a fan of
of x and there i am in that world right
i imagine that you somehow stopped
yourself from calling out the ohio
buckeyes
now i i won't even ask about about uh
connections the fact that i was born in
1947 we'll just we'll leave that one
there are no coincidences
it's in the numbers
all right so i so again as teachers
should we engage right
oftentimes it's easier to shut down
discussion and just move on
right
if the danger of getting into an
extended debate with a student you are
in uncharted territory where you have
left
the area that you have prepared
oftentimes and you are now in a place in
which you have stepped down from the
podium to engage the audience one on one
right this is a dangerous place to be i
recognize that
um
even with debunking there's no guarantee
that the student is gonna be like you've
convinced me oh my god i can't believe i
was so wrong i can guarantee you that
having
literally hundreds of these
conversations that is not going to
happen right so maybe maybe you were
under someone you were under some people
were like well i saw it on the internet
well i'm glad that's not true right so
you do run into that but that's that's
your top line
you know you're going to get from these
conversations right but i think
pretending that these conversations are
not there
keeping the class
the classroom as a kind of space where
these conversations don't happen we
don't have those kinds of conversations
here we don't engage with that is not
setting a bar that they're thinking like
okay it doesn't rise to that level they
simply hold it unquestioned
and that our classrooms or at least my
classroom feels further and further
removed from the ways they think we're
actually discussing how the world works
right
um
i think it allows bad thinking to win
the day right so there are a few ways to
challenge it one is occam's razor and
this is the this undercuts the idea of
conspiracy theories to get more and more
baroque as they move forward right that
if you hear hooves think horses not
zebras right so that if you have this
theory to explain the facts that
involves
aliens and lizard people and all these
other things the thought is do we need
those parts of the conspiracy to make
the conspiracy event explained right
one is another one is falsibility and
it's sometimes nice to do falsifiability
in the beginning of the conversation
which is what evidence can i give you
that can
convince you that it's not true not that
i necessarily have it right so i think
this question about like about religion
and and
um and conspiracies if i was to say what
kind of evidence would i need to give
you that would convince you that this
isn't true and if your answer is well if
you had a report from such and such or
had a picture from such and such or you
had evidence or data about this i would
find that to be convincing if the answer
is nothing nothing you can give me will
ever convince me that this didn't happen
then you are having a religious argument
right if you're having an argument in
which you say there is no evidence that
you can give me there is nothing that
you will give me that will not be
immediately impeached because i believe
this is inherently true and my faith
statement is this is real for me
you are not having an evidentiary based
conversation and at that point you can
really
at that point i think you can stop
having it with the recognition that what
you're saying is then you're not making
a truth claim
you're making a religious statement
and that's
whether you want to debate that in your
classroom is different but at least it
clarifies what your actual conversations
are because the most resting thing is to
actually fight about the evidence
realize that you've won the evidentiary
war and haven't touched the actual
conversation you're having
right
you know and the other one is who
benefits and this is actually the one
i've gotten the most
satisfaction from i think cliff actually
did some of these conversations this was
his conversation with teenagers was
actually asking the same question which
is not to say i think what you just said
is stupid and it's not real not that
y'all would ever do that you guys are
great teachers not that you would ever
say this is untrue and i don't want to
talk about this and this is why it's
untrue and i'm going to shut this down
but instead not shutting and this is a
can be a dangerous path if you don't
know your students right which is not
asking for less but asking for more
right
one of the best statements i found in
the classroom is not to confront
with derision or even contrary evidence
at first but to answer the question why
why would this conspiracy happen
right what is the goal what was the
conspiracy necessary to reach this goal
are there other more simpler or
effective ways what would it take to
pull this off what are the risks why
would it justify the rewards right how
has it stayed secret these kinds of
questions not the questions of i think
you're wrong and i'm arguing with your
world view but talk me through it i've
often said
okay you can do it for 9 11. you can do
it for the flat earth if the flat earth
you say wait so let's just get a sense
of how many people have to be in on the
earth being flat and that number as you
might imagine
is
mind-bendingly large
then the answer is why if the takeaway
is
because
we they don't want evidence of a
god-created world first of all arguments
of a god-created world are doing really
fine in american culture it's not like
they are ignored second of all when
would this conspiracy have had to start
which would have been a lot earlier than
the turn to secularity right you would
have had to start this in the 18th 19th
century in which religion was
unquestionably the center of american
public life and the discovery that the
earth was flat would have been
like many sources such as the catholic
church would have been like hooray but
even the catholic church is off of this
that you know anyone had a bias in
trying to keep the earth flattering the
catholic church
because if this is evidence of a
god-created world then they are
certainly someone who would want that
evidence right the 911 which is
when you think about it the 911 plot is
really complicated it involves a lot of
loose ends and a lot of exposure and a
lot of people being involved in which
we're going to fly we're going gonna
take people who don't know how to fly
and put them in flight schools and then
we'll teach them how to fly but it might
get out and we'll have to keep them all
quiet so they can then
fly their planes into this and what's
the payoff
right if the payoff is
what we get war in the middle east
i mean
i have a
one word for that
it's kuwait
most people can't find kuwait on a map
and in 1991 we were 100 ready maybe not
100
the united states was ready to go to war
for the freedom of kuwait a country that
most of us had never heard of and would
never hear about again after that
it is not that hard to get america to go
into war right i mean this is george w
bush
h.w bush bonesman head of the cia head
of the oil government said oil
corporation iraq must withdraw from
kuwait completely immediately and
without condition kuwait's legitimate
government must be restored the security
and stability of the purging gulf must
be assured iraq will not be permitted to
annex kuwait that's not a threat that's
not a boast that's just the way it's
going to be
right this is an incredibly powerful
statement that the united states
military will back up a country that
people hadn't heard of and most
americans went along with it
you don't need to have four planes hit
four locations
run by people who are largely amateur
pilots to get a war in the middle east
not only that there was a bomb as you
well know there was a bomb that blew up
in the world trade center in 1993 that
could have done a lot more damage if you
want to bring down a tower you can do it
without all of this like you can imagine
in this smoke-filled room
saying you know
bob i love the plan but i think there's
a lot of moving parts here you don't
need this rube goldberg machine if your
goal is war in the middle east
right what you need to do is influence a
handful of senators and representatives
you could have a false flag operation
somewhere where there's no exposure no
risk no extra moving parts even if you
want something spectacular
if the federal government is conspiring
against itself it could blow up the
white house i mean there's a thousand
things you could do that would not
require this complicated of a plan
so why do it right and so part of this
is if the goal is to get something you
can reach in some other way without
exposure why take the complicated way
right
and there are some ironies about these
secret societies one is the i've called
i've labeled these these these are
invented by me
one is the yankee fan 69 paradox this is
the idea that there has been a
let's say generations if not
hundreds of years long secret plan that
involves the masons or the
the templars the masons ufos secret
knowledge the federal government the fed
rothschilds bankers and it stayed secret
until now on the internet yankee fan 69
has figured it out and he's blowing the
doors wide open on this plan so in other
words there's a sense that
you have to believe that this thing is
so large and so secret
that it has stayed secret for so long
but has been discovered by someone doing
research on the internet
and part of that is the riddler
principle which is the belief that the
this idea of the obsession of signs and
symbols
that this conspiracy has kept it secret
and it's managed to keep it secret to do
all of its work but it just can't stop
labeling its work
like it can't stop putting the eye on
the pyramid on money and then on
floating pyramids in space right the
idea that for some reason this
conspiracy is so smart and powerful and
rich and stayed secret for so long but
it just can't help taunting people it's
like yankee fan 69 so that he can put
the pieces together to explode right
and the final one is the irony of power
which is
if you imagine a conspiracy
of huge money
powerful people international scope
the darpa the entire
intelligence apparatus of the united
states behind it that it has infinite
reach it can keep people quiet it can
make people disappear it can kill
witnesses it can use ufos
if it has all this power
why does it need the conspiracy
right
if what you want is war in the middle
east and you have a secret government
that stretches back thousands uh you
know multiple generations that controls
infinite money and infinite power what
you really want is to get a vote in the
senate
you then you don't have like if you have
this power and you want to do this thing
why don't you simply do it
then have a conspiracy to get something
that seems pretty easy to get if you
have infinite money infinite time you
can silence people you have mind control
and you're working with shape-shifting
lizards like you really don't need the
conspiracy
right so there's this sense in which the
power required to keep it secret is
enough power to accomplish the thing the
conspiracy is supposed to do
so
why this complicated middleman
right
conspiracy thinking leads to greater
hatred alienation the population it
results in political apathy
the idea that they lied to us as an
unquestioned concept as a reflexive
notion that we are they lie to us trust
no one is a dangerous thing in a
participating democracy it is allowed to
become not just part of our political
culture but it's a part of our social
culture of our popular culture the idea
of everyone's conspiring against us
and the reality is that people are using
in power
these kinds of conspiracy theories one
to manipulate other people
we've talked about plugging into
people's conspiracy theories to goad
them into particular things sometimes
horrible social policies they're also
guiding
decisions that politicians are making
who are actually part of these
conspiracy theories whether it's you
know about planned parenthood or about
israel different all kinds of different
ideas there are
non-like
there are these kinds of underground
conspiracies that are pushing both
politicians and their voters because
they largely remain unchallenged right
the ability or the lack of ability to
push evidence to ask these questions to
get people to expose these these
conspiracies see where they lie what
they do and how they actually function
in american life because they are
everywhere and they are powerful
and they are largely unchallenged and
we're
the teachers right
um
seeing conspiracies everywhere seeing
everything as a false flag
or a come kind of conspiracy or a scheme
is a kind of studied blindness right it
allows you to not see the world around
you as it's happening as we think it's
happening because you have an
explanation right so every shooting is
just one more false flag every event
that happens is just one more part of a
conspiracy and i'm not going to get
fooled into letting the government take
my guns
so literally whatever happens is not
going to affect my belief because i
already have a set of beliefs to explain
these behaviors right
but it's not just that it's on all of
these issues
having a conspiracy theory that explains
them away means that i don't actually
have to engage with what is occurring
i can simply engage with the conspiracy
that i've already made up which makes me
having to do anything else absolutely
not unnecessary and that's a dangerous
place for us to be as a group as a
people as educators and i think we need
to recognize where our
our fellow americans are right
conspiracies exist they are real right
so we've talked about a number of
different conspiracies right
but so do unsubstantiated conspiracy
theories our students and fellow
citizens they're surrounded by these
types of claims at all time
and our decision to see them as unworthy
of commentary if that is our decision
means not engaging with the primary way
that they see the world right
to matter and this is historians and i
consider you all to be historians
english english teachers
all of us are historians and to not meet
the people where they are with actually
understanding the kinds of things they
believe the kinds of things that make up
their world view and make that part of
our classroom experience as well
i think is turning our back on an
important intervention that we can make
into the way that our city our fellow
students and citizens actually see the
world around them and i think it's
important that we do so
thank you
[Applause]